so one of the most frequent requests
that I've received here on my youtube
channel is a video about Nick Fury and
this makes sense because with the rise
of the popularity of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe a lot of people have
questions about the character Nick Fury
and a lot of people want to know what
his role is in Marvel Comics and
ultimately a lot of people want an
answer to the question why is it that if
Nick Fury is Caucasian and the Marvel
Comics that he's played by Samuel
Jackson who's an african-american in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and so we're
going to answer these questions and
we're going to jump back into the past
to the origins and the very first
appearance of Nick Fury work our way
forward and ultimately answer this
question why is it that Samuel Jackson
who is african-american is playing Nick
Fury in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so
Nick Fury first appeared in Sergeant
fury and as Howling Commandos in May of
1963 he was created by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby and the comic series ran for a
hundred and sixty-seven issues however
by the time the comic book came to a
close all we really saw a reprints of
previous issues what we saw was that
with issues 1 through 80 a new issue was
coming out every single time it was
released but between issues 81 and 120
we saw a combination of reprints in
addition to new issues and with issues
number 121 to 167 we saw a series of
single reprints where there were no new
issues being released
but at the same time what's also most
most important I think about sergeant
fury and as Howling Commandos is that it
broke ground in a lot of different ways
when it came to Marvel Comics the first
being that understand Lee as the writer
and Jack Kirby as the artist we saw our
first african-american character that
was on a main stage and Marvel Comics
and we had never seen this before
Gabe Jones was an african-american who
is fighting alongside other
multicultural individuals or a
multicultural group in Marvel Comics
during World War two and this wasn't
something that you normally saw when you
look at comic books with regards to
World War two you usually always saw
white men fighting you never really saw
women and you never saw anyone of any
other kind of cultural descent you
always saw white Americans and so for
Marvel to release a comic that showed
not only an african-american fighting a
world war two but other people of other
cultures this was something entirely new
and in fact when the first issue was
sent for print what we saw was that Gabe
Jones was actually colored or I guess
recolored as Caucasian because the
printing company thought a mistake had
been made and that they had actually
made an error by making him
african-american of course Stan Lee sent
a letter to the printing company and
stated that gave Jones was supposed to
be an african-american and it wasn't a
mistake
now when I say that Gabe Jones was the
first african-american character I don't
mean to confuse this statement with
individuals such as Falcon or T'Challa
who is Black Panther Black Panther was
the first African superhero and Falcon
was the first African American superhero
so they really kind of broke ground in
their own rights what we also saw was
that in the instance of this this comic
breaking ground the second half of this
was Gary Friedrich and this is was
really kind of interesting here after I
think after the first dozen issues or so
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby stepped away
from the comic and the reason why is
because around the time that sergeant
fury and his Howling Commandos was
released we also saw the Fantastic Four
and spider-man being released however at
the time that Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
had stepped away they had done this
because they
Fantastic Four spider-man and other
comics like them with superheroes were
gaining more prominence and so they
really kind of walked away from sergeant
fury and his Howling Commandos to focus
on those stories we saw that Roy Thomas
had taken over the role of writing and
we saw the dick errors had taken over
the artistic aspect that was left vacant
by Jack Kirby after Roy Thomas had left
we had seen Gary Friedrich take over and
this is where the comic changed entirely
were previously understand Lee and Jack
Kirby and even Roy Thomas the comic had
kind of played this arbitrary
archetypical comic book of the time it
is to say they really kind of fought in
some engagements but there wasn't really
a whole lot to it Gary Friedrich took in
and in the direction of really kind of
asking the reader to challenge their
moral and political philosophies in
terms of what they were reading and how
they related to the world one of the
most notable examples was a story called
the assassin where an individual
encountered the Howling Commandos and he
was a hitman for hire and the reason why
this really called into question moral
philosophy was because he was a hitman
for hire but because his family was
being held hostage by the by the Gestapo
and so the question became if a man puts
a gun to another man's head but does so
to save his family does that make him an
inherently bad person it was stories
like these that were really interesting
and really kind of struck a chord with a
lot of individuals and to this day
remains some of the most popular
storylines of Marvel Comics not
necessarily because of the art artistic
renderings not necessarily because it
was simply overtly asking for morality
you know that is to say the comic wasn't
something along the lines of sergeant
fury and his Howling Commandos and today
we're going to challenge your moral
beliefs it was really just kind of the
idea that it was giving the reader
something else to look at it was giving
the reader something more in depth then
really just kind of an arbitrary fight
that went on between the Howling
Commandos and some kind of villain now
ultimately the Howling Commandos came to
a close but as we'll discuss in the next
section we'll see that Nick Fury
actually appears not only alongside the
Howling Commandos but at the same time
appears as part of the CIA and strange
tales
so Nick Fury became part of strange
tales in August of 1965 with issue
number 135 and initially this was
actually confusing to a lot of people
and even now individuals who were going
back and reading the publication history
of Nick Fury will be thrown off by this
because in effect Marvel was publishing
Nick Fury in two different eras at the
same time and where we saw Nick Fury and
Sergeant fury and his Howling Commandos
being portrayed as a rugged
devil-may-care individual fighting
alongside the Howling Commandos in
strange tales we saw Nick theory being
displayed or being given to us as a
suave and a very charismatic and very
slick CIA agent now the reason for this
was because at the time in the 1960s
James Bond was wildly popular and so
Marvel was looking to get to capitalize
on the popularity of James Bond by
turning Nick Fury who had already been
kind of a soldier into a James Bond kind
of character but what we saw towards the
end of the publication history with
sergeant fury and his Howling Commandos
it is to say between issues 81 and 120
was this sort of migration this sort of
integration between the Nick Fury that
we saw in sergeant fury and his Howling
Commandos and the Nick Fury that we
would come to see and strange tales and
we saw that by the end or towards the
end of Sergeant fury and his Howling
Commandos Nick Fury takes a piece of
shrapnel to the eye and so we're kind of
left to presume that over the course of
the time between the end of World War
two and the time when he is recruited by
the CIA as a spy
and strange tales that ultimately the
damage to his eye necessitated an
eyepatch and that's one of the reasons
why Nick Fury wears his signature piece
of equipment now over the course of the
strange tales comics we really kind of
see Nick Fury evolve and become the
character that we have become the most
familiar with but during the strange
tales comics we saw the integration and
the inclusion and the development of
some of the groups that Nick Fury would
both become a
member of and a help to in addition to
an enemy of in in the strange tales
comics we saw the formation of shield
and of course we also saw the return of
one of the most notable villains of Nick
Fury Baron von Strucker now Baron von
Strucker first appeared in sergeant fury
and his Howling Commandos issue number 5
and at the time he was really just kind
of a Nazi officer but by the time Nick
Fury was in strange tales Baron von
Strucker had become leader of Hydra and
Hydra ultimately became the enemy of
shield now over the course of the
publication history of Nick Fury as we
move beyond strange tales we begin to
see that Nick Fury actually gets his own
solo series and Nick Fury agent of
shield vol 1 now this comes about with
the end of the strange tales comics
which had switched over to dr. Strange's
own comics after issue number 168 in
1968 and what we see with Nick Fury
agent of shield is that he has in fact
become the director of shield and as
Nick Fury is now in charge of shield it
begins to grow and it begins to flourish
more that it previously had
but then we begin to see that shield
starts to change we begin the shield I
begin to see the shield really kind of
goes in a direction that Nick Fury isn't
necessarily a fan of and the reason for
this is because at this time when Nick
Fury is the director of shield he's
actually not running shield shield
itself is ran by 12 anonymous
individuals that we never learned the
identity of what we see playing out and
the reason for Nick Fury's
disillusionment with shield is the
existence of life model decoys which had
previously been introduced some strange
tales and were robotic decoys of various
shield agents becoming sentient that is
to say gaining their own intelligence
and ultimately launching a campaign
whereby they replaced shield agents with
android replications we ultimately see
that Nick Fury is able to defeat the the
LMD threat or at the time they were
called del tides but we see that at the
same time he disbands shield now
ultimately shield is reformed by Nick
Fury
but it's reformed in such a way to where
it's much smaller
previously been but it was still just as
effective as that had previously been we
also see that over the course of the
publication history of Nick Nick Fury
that he begins to lose his solo comic
the Nick Fury agent of shield comic
actually goes away and it was pretty
short-lived it was only about 15 or 16
issues I think and despite the fact that
he had some other solo runs that popped
up it didn't last very long he remained
a mainstay in the background of a lot of
characters and in fact there has not
been a comic book series belonging to a
major superhero or a major superhero
group where Nick Fury has never appeared
in addition we also see that there are
some storylines that come to fruition
where Nick Fury appears or is a major
part of for example and one of the more
interesting stories and in fact what
people consider to be one of the best
stories in Marvel Comics The Secret
Invasion we learned that Nick Fury is
actually the first one to realize that
the alien race the scrolls who are the
mortal enemy of the Kree and our
shape-shifting race of aliens have
infiltrated the planet earth and began
replacing superheroes and individuals
alike
with scroll copies of these individuals
we see that Nick Fury actually goes
underground he disappears for quite some
time and he was able to organize a team
together to sort of launch a
counter-attack and this pretty much is
kind of how it plays out with Nick Fury
we don't really see him playing a great
big huge role in Marvel comics after his
solo series really kind of come to an
end we see a reformation and a return of
some members of the Howling Commandos
and then in 2005 we actually see a new
version of the Howling Commandos but
it's really not the same but despite the
fact that Nick Fury really didn't have a
long-running solo series he has really
kind of been a mainstay in Marvel Comics
and pretty much appears almost anywhere
and if there is a major storyline
involving a multitude of superheroes you
can almost always bet the Nick Fury
somewhere is going to appear and play a
role
so the question that I imagine most
people have at this point whether you're
unfamiliar with Nick Fury and have seen
this video in an effort to learn more
about his publication history or if
you're relatively familiar with Nick
Fury but not as knowledgeable that as
other versions is why is Samuel Jackson
playing the role of Nick Fury and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
when Nick Fury in the comics was
Caucasian and Samuel Jackson is
african-american in truth this question
is actually not the best way to phrase
it there actually is an African American
version of Nick Fury in Marvel Comics
but it's not in the mainstream comics
that we've read or the comics that we've
discussed in this video
there actually came a point where by
marvel created something called the
ultimate universe and the Ultimate
Universe was really just kind of a way
for Marvel to not necessarily reboot
characters but to have characters gain
their powers or come together as a group
in a different way and the reason for
this was because virtually all other
alternate universe versions of Marvel
Comics that we had seen we had really
just kind of picked up in the middle of
everything for example with the Days of
Future past we learned that there are
still some x-men around although not in
the same capacity and there are not the
same individuals but we don't really
know how it was that they came together
as a group we don't really know if they
gained their powers the same way we
don't really know what road they took
leading up to that point we can presume
for the most part that was probably the
same due to the fact that the only
difference between that universe and the
mainstream universe was the
assassination of Senator Robert Kelley
but it's not given to us as an absolute
with the Ultimate Universe it was given
to us that way we saw individuals like
spider-man and the Fantastic Four gain
their powers different ways or in
similar ways but with slight changes
Nick Fury was one of these individuals
that came about a different way but we
actually see Nick Fury reimagined in an
entirely new way in the Ultimate
Universe Nick Fury is a general and in
the ultimate near verse Nick Fury is
african-american now as I understand it
Samuel Jackson actually did not give his
permission for Marvel to use his
likeness and Marvel had actually created
Nick Fury to look almost
exactly like samuel l.jackson now I
don't really know what steps were taken
after Samuel Jackson learned that is
like this was being used but at this
point I'd say that the only thing we can
really do is kind of delve into the
realm of conjecture speculation and just
haphazard guessing and say that there
were probably a series of closed-door
meetings that were probably some
non-disclosure agreements signed some
royalties paid and ultimately Samuel
Jackson is playing the role of Nick Fury
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe it
could also be that because Samuel
Jackson looks exactly like the character
Nick Fury in the Ultimate Universe and
the character was designed to look like
Samuel Jackson that it was just a good
idea on behalf of somebody at Marvel
someone who was as part of the creative
team and part of the decision-making
team and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
may have simply just sat down and said
hey this guy looks like Samuel Jackson
he was designed to look like Samuel
Jackson why not just have Samuel Jackson
play the role ultimately I don't really
know here I don't know what goes on
behind closed doors in Marvel
headquarters but it seems to me that
most likely in agreement was struck
between Samuel Jackson and Marvel so
that Samuel Jackson would play the role
of Nick Fury in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so Nick Fury doesn't really
have any superpowers he is pretty much a
garden-variety human but because of the
fact that he has fought in World War 2
alongside or in addition to the Korean
War and the Vietnam War in addition to
being a CIA spy and the director of
shield he is pretty much the guy who's
done it all he is the quintessential
military strategist on the planet Earth
in the Marvel Universe there really
isn't anyone who's as capable as he is
in the realm of military strategy in
addition Nick Fury is for the most part
immortal now there's some debate about
this in terms of whether or not he is
actually immortal now but there was a
point in world war 2 whereby he was
injured and he was subjected to a dose
of something called the Infinity formula
and as long as he took the Infinity
formula
annually it would maintain his youth now
eventually he stops taking the Infinity
formula and actually gives the last
remnants of the Infinity formula to
Bucky Barnes in order to save his life
but Marvel says that because there were
trace amounts left in his body and that
they will always be in his body as long
as he doesn't have a blood transfusion
that he will remain immortal in addition
it was passed down to his son just
because of the fact that as part of his
DNA now and so his son Nick Fury jr. is
immortal now whether or not that means
that his son Nick Fury will actually age
or it'll simply be like a like a mutant
gene where it will become active at a
certain point we don't really know but
what we do know is that Nick Fury
remains ageless and that's the reason
why he always looks the same whenever
you look at him in Marvel Comics whether
you look at Nick Fury from the his I
guess the strange tale storylines were
Nick Fury in the secret Wars he's always
the same he is always armed sorry Nick
Fury another Secret Invasion he's always
the same he never looks any different in
addition to this Nick Fury also has very
powerful individuals in his corner he
has the Avengers the Fantastic Four he
also has some very intelligent
individuals in his corner
Bruce Banner Peter Parker Reed Richards
and so he always has access to virtually
the best of intelligence in addition to
the best of technologies that are in the
possession of shield so in truth I don't
really know there's much that we can do
in the way of speculation when it comes
to Nick Fury in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe outside of what role he may
play or if he may return in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe after the events of
Captain America the Winter Soldier this
is really kind of interesting when you
look at this idea of the role of Nick
Fury and his supposed death although we
know that he is alive after the events
of Captain America the Winter Soldier
and these events really kind of run
parallel with the events of the del
tides and the Marvel Comics and it
really kind of seems to me that despite
the fact that it wasn't a rogue group of
sentient androids that it replace
individuals that were part of shield and
ultimately resulted in a Nick Fury
disbanding shield it seems to me that
bull most likely happened is that Nick
Fury will return and will reform shield
and it will be very similar in the way
that we saw in Marvel
comics in the sense that shield will be
smaller but it'll be more controlled by
Nick Fury he will be the absolute
authority and shield because as we've
seen in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Nick Fury was not directly in control of
shield the control of shield actually
followed parallel with Marvel Comics in
the sense that it was an anonymous group
of individuals that were giving the
orders now
unlike what we saw and the Avengers we
we didn't know what the who the
individuals were in Marvel Comics as we
mentioned but for me I really do hope to
see that Nick Fury returns I really
would like to see his character return
because in truth I think the Samuel
Jackson has done a fantastic job acting
out the role of Nick Fury and he really
kind of seems to be one of these
individuals who is able to play the role
in such a way but you really couldn't
see anybody else playing it you know I'm
not sure how you feel about the
character of Nick Fury as he's been
portrayed by samuel l.jackson but I
really couldn't see anybody else doing
the job I mean he really has the
charisma he has the character down pat
you know you really believe that he has
this understanding of what it means to
be a spy of what it means to play out
the role of a person who is both
suspicious about the world around him
but recognizes that there are
individuals that he does have to trust
to some degree in order for him to be
able to function in the role that's been
assigned to him so I really do hope the
character does return I really do hope
that we see Nick Fury again as I
understand it Nick Fury is going to have
a very minimal role in the Avengers age
of Ultron and this makes sense because
with Nick Fury there were several times
when he went underground where there
were events where he normally would have
appeared but we simply just didn't see
him but we are going to see hopefully I
see Nick Fury in future versions
hopefully we'll see Nick Fury in Captain
America 3 hopefully we'll see Nick Fury
and the film about Ant Man because it
really would be disappointing to see
someone like Samuel Jackson who plays
the role so well ultimately not return
to that role after the events of Captain
America and the Winter Soldier with that
being said I'm gonna go ahead bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later peace
now in issues number 44 through 47 what
we learn is that Madame Medusa is part
of a group called the Inhumans and at
some point prior to issue number 36 of
the fantastic for Madame Medusa had
suffered from amnesia she had been in
some sort of a plane a plane crash I
think we see that ultimately